die menschheit beginnt mit einer neuen
ära bei ita dem absolut riesigen
kernfusionsreaktor geht es in die
schlussphase des baus einige fachleute
halten die kernfusion für eine art
wundermittel mit dem fusionsreaktor iter
will man durch die verschmelzung von
wasserstoff atom billige und fast
unbegrenzte energiegewinn gelingt es uns
die prozesse der sonne zu imitieren und
die menschheit damit vor einer
vernichtenden klimakatastrophe zu
bewahren klicks zum science and future
gibt es dreimal pro woche spannende
science wie das abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur dann verpasst
er nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
clixoom gibt es jetzt übrigens auch auf
die ohren und zwar als podcast die links
zu spotify und apple podcast sind unten
in der video beschreibung
laut der internationalen fachleute in
südfrankreich ist es ein zitat
meilenstein denen das it projekt in
diesen tagen erreicht hat ende mai
konnte das erste riesige große teil des
reaktors in die sogenannte tokamak basis
versenkt werden
es handelt sich um nicht weniger als die
größte hochvakuum druckkammer die jemals
von menschenhand geschaffen wurde
so waren riesige kräne notwendig um die
1250 tonnen schwere kost art basis zu
bewegen in der pressemitteilung des
unternehmens heißt es unter den
zuschauern herrscht ein intensives
staunen und eine große erwartung man hat
das gefühl dass die menschheit eine neue
ära beginnt die aktuellen arbeiten auf
dem gelände werden hier mit der
schlussszene eine steven spielberg films
aus dem jahr 1977 verglichen unheimliche
begegnung der dritten art hier schwebt
ein riesiges außerirdisches raumschiff
über der erde
dass die menschen zugleich ängstlich und
ehrfürchtig beobachten und tatsächlich
die bilder von der installation des
riesigen element sind beeindruckend in
der offiziellen pressemitteilung heißt
es weiter mit der installation machte
die menschheit einen entscheidenden
schritt zur realisierung der
fusionsenergie durch die bereitstellung
sauberer sicherer und unbegrenzte
energie
der weitere verlauf der zivilisation
verändert werden dieser satz macht
deutlich welch große hoffnung auf der
kernfusionstechnik ruhen und welch
riesiges potenzial
bereits seit den 50er jahren tüfteln
forschungsteams weltweit mit großer
anstrengung daran die sonne zu imitieren
konkret geht es darum durch die
verschmelzung von wasserstoff atom
energie zu gewinnen so wie es eben auch
in der sonne passiert und das wäre in
vielerlei hinsicht eigentlich viel zu
schön um wahr zu sein denn so ließe sich
tatsächlich eine sehr billige energie
herstellen und das fast in unbegrenzter
menge
das ganze könnte zudem auch noch äußerst
umweltfreundlich ablaufen denn bei der
kernfusionstechnik wird weder die natur
verschmutzt noch werden treibhausgase in
die atmosphäre abgegeben anders als in
einem atomkraftwerk werden atomkerne in
einem fusionsreaktor nicht gespalten
sondern fusioniert und bei dieser
verschmelzung wird dann eben eine menge
energie frei 2 leichter atome bilden
land also ein schweres die gesamtmasse
des neuen atoms ist geringer als die der
beiden einzeln das was fehlt ist die
entstanden energie feststeht was dabei
herauskommen könnte ist enorm ein gramm
der brennstoffe könnte in einem
fusionsreaktor so viel energie liefern
wie sie bei der verbrennung von achtung
elf tonnen kohle entsteht doch das alles
ist viel einfacher gesagt als getan denn
dazu müssen schwere wasserstoff atomen
namens tritium und deuterium zueinander
gebracht werden damit diese dann
letztendlich miteinander reagieren und
das obwohl sich deren kerne abstoßen der
trick dabei eine sehr heiße umgebung im
interpret soll ein plasma mit einer
temperatur von 150 millionen grad
erzeugt werden und dass es deutlich
heißer als in der sonne selbst bedingt
durch den geringen druck auf der erde
obwohl das ziemlich extrem klingt bringt
diese technologie neben der
klimafreundlichkeit einen weiteren
entscheidenden vorteil mit sich der
ganze prozess ist sehr viel
ungefährlicher als die atom spaltung in
kernkraftwerken wie wir sie heute kennt
denn selbst bei einem unfall setzt ein
fusionsreaktor nicht die unmengen an
radioaktiver strahlung frei wie ein
kernkraftwerk und zudem haben die
radioaktiven stoffe die hierbei
entstehen
halbwertszeit von jahrzehnten und eben
nicht von jahrmillionen so wie es eben
beim atomkraftwerk der fall ist die
hoffnung dabei ist es eine
unerschöpfliche energiequelle zu
erschließen und das ist wirklich der
kernpunkt es geht um unerschöpfliche
energie es wäre wahrscheinlich für
unsere zivilisation ein riesiger schritt
ein kern fusionskraftwerk dass eine
unmenge an energie produziert und zwar
ohne wind sonne öl oder gas ja ohne
davon abhängig zu sein alle
energieprobleme auf dieser erde könnten
somit möglicherweise auf einen schlag
gelöst werden das internationale
fusionsprojekt inter geht jetzt also in
die heiße phase bis ende des kommenden
jahres 2021 sollen alle bauteile auf die
großbaustelle südfranzösischen
forschungszentrums karasch geschafft
werden es ist tatsächlich die größte
baustelle europas so große achtung 60
fußballfelder in fünf jahren dann im
dezember 2025 soll der reaktor den
plänen der verantwortlichen zufolge das
erste mal eingeschaltet werden dazu
dahinter direktor bernard pivot in einem
interview mit dem fachmagazin science
wenn sie jahrelang an etwas gearbeitet
haben und sehen dass es real wird sind
sie aufgeregt sie fühlen sich auch
verantwortlich weil sie das vertrauen so
vieler menschen haben hinter steht
übrigens für international
thermonukleare experimental reactor die
lateinische bedeutung ist weg und
tatsächlich war es bis zu dem jetzigen
zeitpunkt ein sehr langer weg und zwar
einen weg der ganzen menschheit das
projekt zwar wurde schon mehrmals
verschoben und auch der finanzielle
rahmen wurde mehr als gesprengt
ursprünglich war man mal von 5
milliarden euro ausgegangen mittlerweile
werden die kosten auf mehr als 20
milliarden euro geschätzt aber getragen
wird das projekt von fast der gesamten
welt unter anderem von
eu-mitgliedstaaten russland china den
usa und südkorea 2015 beispielsweise
wurde plötzlich klar dass sich der start
um fünf jahre verzögern wird doch alle
haben mitgezogen und der itr direktor
hat in einem interview mit dem spiegel
gesagt es gibt nicht so viele
alternativen um saubere und nachhaltige
energie zu produzieren wenn wir erfolg
haben erschließen wir eine klimaneutrale
fast unerschöpfliche energiequelle die
überall verfügbar ist
technisch gesehen basiert auf dem
töpfermarkt prinzip das konzept des
tokamak reaktors ist nicht neu ist wurde
schon 1952 von 52 jahren in moskau
entwickelt der begriff druckermarkt
heißt übrigens übersetzt so viel wie
tore ideale kammer in magnetspulen wobei
die silbe talk auf strom hindeutet und
somit die besonderheit des tk maxx
prinzip hervorhebt den stromfluss im
plasma das magnetfeld wird hier zum teil
von einem im plasma fließenden strom
erzeugt das konzept beim töpfermarkt
basiert also auf dem magnetischen
einschluss bei der technologie wird also
ein ringförmiges magnetfeld erzeugt
dieses schließt das heißt wasserstoff
plasma ein unbändiges so vom prinzip her
ähnelt diese stalker markt prinzip dem
stellarator prinzip dieses wird derzeit
den kreisweit erprobt bei dem projekt
wendelstein 7-x geht es darum das
verhalten von heißen plasma zu
analysieren und in den griff zu bekommen
der unterschied beim separator sind es
ausschließlich externe magnete mit denen
das magnetfeld erzeugt wird das ist beim
töpfermarkt des inter reaktors anders
hier setzt man auf die kombination von
starkem strom in plasma selbst und einem
magnetfeld das extern erzeugt wird auch
das ziel ist ein anderes beim inter ist
ein funktionierender fusionsreaktor das
ziel in greifswald geht es nur nur in
anführungszeichen um ein besseres
verständnis des plasmas beim inter
projekt erhofft man sich durch den
reifen förmigen magnetfeld käfig dass
man das plasma deutlich länger zusammen
halten kann
das würde die sogenannte energie
einschluss zeit optimieren in sachen
plasma volumen von 8 140 kubikmetern ist
etwa im verhältnis von volumen zur
oberfläche absoluter spitzenreiter so
sollen verlust prozesse so gering wie
möglich gehalten werden die pläne sind
nicht ohne und in der letzten stufe soll
etwa 500 megawatt fusions leistungen
erzeugen dass es halb so viel
wir waren klassischen kernkraftwerk
heute und das bei einem prototyp das ist
schon eine menge aber nicht nur der
fusions leistungswert an sich ist von
großer bedeutung sondern vor allem auch
das verhältnis der fusions leistung zur
externen heizleistung also wie viel
steckt mal rein wie viel kommt raus in
diesem zusammenhang wichtig der
sogenannte q wert dass es der
verstärkung faktor der bisherige rekord
liegt bei q gleichen 0,7 also es geht
starker verluste noch etat soll den wert
10 erreichen womit das erste mal ein
wert größer als 1 realisiert würde also
zum ersten mal energie gewonnen würde
die eu-kommission ist optimistisch und
hat den kernfusionsreaktor als klima
rettungsmaßnahme erklärt alle
finanziellen zuschüsse die inter
zukünftig zu gute kommen sollen als
klimaschutzmaßnahme deklariert werden
diese überlegungen basieren auch auf dem
sogenannten green deal der eu-kommission
demzufolge 25 prozent des eu budgets in
den klimaschutz gesteckt werden sollen
klar ist wenn die kernfusion
funktioniert dann ist sie nicht mit
schädlichen emissionen verbunden und
somit mindestens genau so erstrebenswert
wie die erneuerbare energie doch es gibt
zwei haken zum einen ist die kern
versuchen alles andere als günstig nach
angaben der bundesregierung hat die
europäische union im zeitraum zwischen
2014 und 2020 2,7 milliarden euro für
ihn ausgegeben
in den gesamten bereich der
atomforschung gingen insgesamt sogar 5
milliarden euro
dagegen haben alle nicht nuklearen
bereich nur knapp sechs milliarden euro
als zuschuss programmen darunter zählen
natürlich auch die erneuerbaren energien
und genau das ist ein großer kritikpunkt
denn die riesige menge an finanziellen
mitteln die bislang bereits in die
fusionsforschung geflossen sind fehlt
nach ansicht der kritikerinnen und
kritiker an anderer stelle
beispielsweise in der forschung zu
energieeffizienz und -speicherung wenn
die nahe zukunft laufen derzeit noch den
verhandlungen aber der plan der eu
kommission sieht vor die finanziellen
zuschüsse für das inter projekt sogar
noch zu erhöhen
bis 2027 könnten dann gelder von sechs
milliarden euro fließen
das wäre rekord denn bislang wurde keine
andere energietechnologie finanziell so
dermaßen unterstützt auch die
finanzielle unterstützung aus den usa
scheint erstmal gesichert us präsident
donald trump hat in die förderung von
zwei jahren 2018 verdoppelt dabei hatten
die usa schon vor einigen jahren ihre
ungeduld kundgetan der zweite große
haken an der kernfusionsforschung die
technologie ist noch lange noch lange
nicht ausgereift wird es jemals möglich
sein mehr energie zu produzieren als
reingesteckt wird dabei handelt es sich
um eine ganze menge denn dass das war
der wirklich ultra hoch erhitzt das soll
ja schaffen wird es den forschungsteams
bereits in der nahen zukunft gelingen
ein plasma strom in einem
fusionskraftwerk dauerhaft am brennen zu
halten und welches material hält den
krassen belastungen an der innenwand des
plasma gefäßes über einen längeren
zeitraum stand da ist bei etr nach
wahrscheinlich maximal zehn minuten
schluss
der physiker michael dittmar ist
skeptisch und sagt dem spiegel interview
das erreichte sollte nur in relation zu
den versprechungen der letzten 20 bis 30
jahre gesehen werden ist nur ein
prototyp der stützen für die
grundlagenforschung interessant ist
letztendlich geht es darum wie das passt
mal für ein paar sekunden auf 150
millionen grad erhitzt werden kann der
wissenschaftler aus zürich hatte im
vergangenen jahr einen gutachten zur
kernfusion erstellt und war dabei zu
niederschmetternden ergebnissen gekommen
auf dessen grundlage stützt sich auch
die kritik der grünen die die
technologie als zitat verpackungs
schwindel bezeichnet fest steht
jedenfalls in naher zukunft können wir
uns nicht auf die kernfusion als
klimaretter berufen denn erst in 15
jahren sollen die ersten richtigen
experimente mit deuterium und tritium
starten
der erste wichtige schritt wird also
hoffentlich hoffentlich 2035 erfolgen
hier muss es dann aber auch gelingen
dass fusionsverein color rasch 2035 zu
entzünden doch selbst damit wäre unser
großes klimaproblem natürlich noch lange
nicht gelöst denn es soll ja erst einmal
nur demonstrieren dass kernfusion
machbar ist erst sein nachfolger mit der
bezeichnung demo könnte dann tatsächlich
in betrieb genommen werden um strom zu
erzeugen und zwar frühestens 2050 und
natürlich auch unter der voraussetzung
dass inter ein erfolg wird für die
rettung der erde ist das aber zu spät
dazu manfred fischedick vom wuppertal
institut für klima umwelt energie
die globalen probleme müssen bis 2050
gelöst werden dafür kommt etwas zu spät
wenn bis dahin die pariser
klimaschutzziele nicht erfüllt würden
drohen seiner ansicht nach zitat nicht
mehr beherrschbare veränderung des
erdsystems bleibt uns also nur die
hoffnung dass die erneuerbaren energien
bis dahin die versorgung mit strom
übernehmen könnten zumindest sind sie im
moment die einzige lösung die nicht die
umwelt verseucht wie funktioniert
kernfusion eigentlich genau das erklärt
dr watson hier in diesem video also an
anschauen und abonnieren cedric macht
immer nur einfach gute videos also bis
dann bleib dran